soon this kind of small print will
become a thing of the past as consumers
regain control over the processing and
retention of their personal data
Parliament's approval on the 14th of
April 2016 will set in place common data
protection rules for the EU in all
Member States citizen will have them
quite the same and quite a strong
framework and cut the strong set of
rules which enables them really to
become owners of the day time consumers
will be guaranteed clear information on
the use of personal data and must give
their consent before any data is stored
a simple request and the data must be
deleted otherwise known as the right to
be forgotten also out will be Facebook
and snapchat accounts for children who
don't obtain parental consent but the
new rules have left some MEP skeptical
to say the least regarding the economic
benefits it is not very good for our
competition regarding other regions in
the world we don't have this very
bureaucracy situation member states will
have two years to comply with the new
rules
you